i
[Música]
hola muy buenos días bienvenidos a este
avance informativo en france24 soy raúl
blanco como siempre un gusto
acompañarlos esta mañana iniciamos en
perú donde avanza el conteo de los votos
tras la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales que tuvo lugar el pasado
domingo 6 de junio ya se contabilizó más
del 99 por ciento de las actas veamos
cómo están los resultados hasta el
momento el candidato pedro castillo
quien ya se dio por ganador mantiene una
estrecha ventaja con el 50 punto 21 por
ciento de los sufragios contra un 49
puntos 78 por ciento de los votos para
keiko fujimori para ampliar esta
información saludo en este momento a
nuestro corresponsal enigma francisco
zacarías francisco muy buen día un gusto
saludarlos keiko fujimori presentará un
recurso de nulidad de 800 actas lo que
representa aproximadamente 200 mil votos
que ocurrirá tras esta decisión
francisco
buen día estamos hablando de 200 mil
votos que podrían marcar la diferencia
en el conteo final la estrategia de
keiko fujimori y sus asesores legales es
reducir los votos de pedro casilla y
conforme a esto la oficina nacional de
procesos electorales la declara
triunfadora de estos comicios el jurado
nacional de elecciones tiene tres días
para resolver este caso la sentencia
puede ser apelada mientras tanto este
pedido de nulidad de keiko fujimori le
impide a la oficina nacional de procesos
electorales declarar a un vencedor de
estos comicios
ahora porque con casi el 100% de las
actas escrutadas no se conoce un
resultado final hasta el momento cuando
puede esperarse entonces el anuncio
oficial por parte de las autoridades
electorales
bueno en realidad el proceso de la
oficina nacional de procesos electorales
está avanzando para ellos es rápido pero
para los peruanos y para la comunidad
internacional es lento a qué se debe
esta lentitud porque tienen que
contabilizar los votos que vienen del
extranjero y en mayor proporción lo que
retrasa más es los votos que vienen del
interior del perú especialmente de las
zonas rurales hay las zonas que son este
muy agrestes de difícil acceso también
el clima tiene una implicancia en el
traslado de los votos y toda vez que se
presenten recursos de nulidad y también
impugnaciones estos retrasan más el
conteo de votos y en este caso este
pedido de nulidad de keiko fujimori que
intervienen otras autoridades
electorales pone a paso más lento esta
situación hablando con algunos
entendidos expertos en esta materia
electoral peruana me señalan que esto
puede demorar unos cinco a diez días más
en el mejor de los casos porque tiene
pendiente también una apelación que
pueda
el grupo de pedro castillo francisco
gracias por la información por supuesto
muy pendientes a lo que ocurre en perú
en torno a estas elecciones
presidenciales el reino unido- la
primera parada de su gira europea el
presidente de estadounidense joe biden
se reunirá con el primer ministro
británico boris johnson donde se espera
que hablen de las tensiones en irlanda
del norte debido al brad pitt la reunión
entre los líderes tienen lugar un día
antes de la cumbre del g7 que se
desarrollará de viernes a domingo además
de una cumbre de la otan el día lunes
una cumbre entre eeuu y la unión europea
el martes y una reunión de bailén con el
presidente ruso vladimir putin en
ginebra- el día miércoles el líder de la
casa blanca intentará recobrar las
relaciones multilaterales después de la
presidencia de donald trump que dejó a
muchos aliados de eeuu en europa y asia
muy alejados
y el secretario general de la
organización de estados américanos oea
solicitó realizar una reunión de
urgencia ante lo que calificó como una
arremetida sin precedentes del gobierno
de daniel ortega contra la oposición de
cara a las elecciones presidenciales del
7 de noviembre almagro consideró que en
nicaragua se produjo una alteración del
orden constitucional y exigió la
liberación de los opositores arrestados
las autoridades nicaragüenses han
detenido en los últimos días a cuatro
aspirantes a la presidencia en las
próximas elecciones en las que el
mandatario el sandinista daniel ortega
busca la reelección
al 2 y de esta manera llegamos al final
del avance informativo continua con
nosotros muy buen día
[Música]